andrés muy buenas noches debido a las
polémicas y presiones en las que se vio
envuelto el hasta hoy primer ministro
guido venido el presidente pedro casi o
le exigió su renuncia y justamente esta
tarde un sorpresivo mensaje a los
peruanos pedro castillo señaló que tomó
decisiones en favor de la gobernabilidad
del perú y una de estas ha sido aceptar
la renuncia de guido vido el mandatario
ha señalado que llama a la unión de los
sectores económicos políticos y sociales
del país para continuar con la
gobernabilidad y con lo que su gobierno
se había trazado metas a seguir el
mandatario ha dicho que a las 8 de la
noche va a juramentar a su nuevo
gobierno de ministros con el nuevo jefe
del gabinete y ahí la pregunta del
millón es que todos se hacen quién va a
ser el nuevo primer ministro hay
diversos nombres que se están barajando
y el más fuerte es mirtha vásquez
quienes ha sido mejor dicho ex
presidenta del parlamento peruano
durante la gestión del ex presidente
francisco sagasti pero que habría sido
lo que habría motivado a pedro casi a
elegirla como primera ministra sería que
ella es una abogada que tiene prestigio
y también es natural de cajamarca región
a la que pertenece el mandatario peruano
esto ha sido uno de los factores para
inclinar la balanza
la renuncia de que ido venido ha
generado diversos tipos de reacciones en
la principal ha sido de la presidenta
del parlamento peruano la señora maría
del carmen alba quien ha visto con
agrado el cambio que ha hecho el
presidente de castilla y ha señalado que
está dispuesta al diálogo ya la
gobernabilidad por otro lado la lideresa
opositora keiko fujimori horas antes
había hecho un llamado al mandatario
para que considere remover el cargo
apellido porque señalaba que le estaba
haciendo muchos daños al país en la otra
vereda el partido oficialista
perú libre que ha llevado al poder a
pedro casi o ha llamado a los
parlamentarios de la bancada oficialista
para tomar acciones a seguir estaremos
ampliando la información más